hi there steve kaufman here  you want to be a champion  i'm not a champion  but i know what i have to do to be in  shape  i have to exercise i have to work at it  i can't just read about how to get in  shape i actually have to do it in  language learning it's the same  grammar isn't going to help you  speak the language you need words  and how do you get words you have to  engage with the language you have to  read you have to listen you have to be  involved with the language reading about  it reading grammar trying to remember  grammar rules trying to apply grammar  rules that you don't really understand  that well isn't gonna do it you have to  exercise  you may not be a champion i'm not a  champion but i enjoy exercising and i  enjoy learning words discovering words  so  do the same  and go to my blog thelinguis.com  and get my 10 secrets to language  learning